elles ont 18 mois de travail pour créer
un projet de territoire les villes de
ben et de jouars-pontchartrain font
partie du projet petite ville de demain
des problématiques communes comme des
espaces publics à requalifier où le
patrimoine d'autres plus spécifiques à
ben le collège doit être reconstruit
d'ici 2026 pour accueillir 850 élèves
une fois le collège je détruis de
revitaliser tout ce car tout ce quartier
où il ya le collège
il ya aussi le gymnase lui aussi pas de
choses on a une gare routière aussi lé
parking tout refaire ce quartier là
peut-être faire une place je ne sais pas
quoi c'est une idée qui passe comme ça a
payé
une place comme dans un village du côté
de jouars-pontchartrain la problématique
est principalement lié à la circulation
la ville est actuellement traversées par
la d900 12 il ya des problèmes des
changeurs de la nationale 12 cantons en
bas de la commune à l'entrée de ville
ouest
en fait l'état construit un
demi-échangeur terre tout est là pour
que l'échangeur soit en double
circulation mais ces échangeurs on ne
peut aller que dans le sens vers dreux
c'est à dire tous les gens qui viennent
du bassin sud qui ont besoin de prendre
la n12 par paris pourrait le prendre à
ce demi échangeur mais n'est pas ouvert
ils sont obligés de traverser notre
commune je vois qu'on chante là pour
aller prendre plus haut niveau de sainte
apolline le travail se fera aussi en
lien avec les habitants des deux
communes
un chef de projet a été nommé huit
autres villes yvelinois sont concernées
trois milliards d'euros sont estimés par
le gouvernement pour les 1600 communes
retenues